Flugzeuge vergiften uns heimlich
durch wolkenähnliche Chemtrails!
Reptilien-Aliens regieren die Welt!
Wir leben auf der Innenseite
einer hohlen Erdkugel!
Im Internet findet anscheinend
jede Theorie ihre Anhänger –
egal, wie weit hergeholt sie
auch klingen mag.
Der Psychologe Sebastian Bartoschek
beschäftigt sich mit diesem
digitalen Phänomen.
Das Netz ist ein guter Nährboden
für die Verbreitung von
Verschwörungstheorien,
weil ich gezielt Sachen suchen kann,
die zu meiner Weltsicht passen –
und weil ich völlig ungefiltert auch
Informationen reinstellen kann.
Das heißt, wo man früher mühevoll
Leute suchen musste,
die ähnliche seltsame Gedanken haben,
finde ich das sofort
heutzutage im Internet.
Ein aktuelles Beispiel:
der durchgestrichene Barcode
auf den Flaschen der Lammsbräu Brauerei.
Ein Kunde fragte im Netz
nach dem Grund dafür.
Antwort des Bio-Bierbrauers:
„Manche Menschen glauben, dass
Barcodes schädliche Energien bündeln.
Wir stehen der Theorie
neutral gegenüber.“
Ist das Kundenservice?
Ein Marketing-Gag? Oder Spinnerei?
Im Netz wird das kontrovers diskutiert.
Diana Paul kennt diese Diskussion.
Sie arbeitet für „Sonnentor“,
ein Unternehmen, das biologische
Gewürze und Tees herstellt.
Auch diese Firma hatte ihre
Barcodes durchstreichen lassen –
und damit angeblich entschärft.
Gegner hatten ihr vorgeworfen,
Verschwörungstheorien zu unterstützen.
Daraufhin verzichtete „Sonnentor“
auf den Strich.
Das kam über Facebook,
das wurde über … auf Blogs publiziert,
und da ging dann eine
regelrechte Welle los.
Und da haben wir uns dann einfach
noch mal auch intensiver
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt
und haben gesagt:
Ok, wenn das gerade unsere
Kunden so polarisiert,
dann schauen wir uns
das noch mal genauer an.
Sebastian Bartoschek rät Unternehmen,
Kundenwünsche genau zu prüfen.
Denn Verschwörungstheoretiker
nutzen jede Möglichkeit,
um ihr Weltbild zu bestätigen.
Wenn jetzt angesehene Firmen
in irgendeiner Form
verschwörungstheoretischen Gedanken
entgegenkommen,
sei es durch das Durchstreichen von
Barcodes oder dadurch, dass sie sagen,
gewisse Elemente seien nicht
mehr in ihren Deosprays,
dann kriegt das auf einmal
’ne Legitimierung.
Und somit wird aus einem Marketing-Gag
letztlich auf einmal ein …
ein quasi Wahrheitsbeleg.
Doch im Netz tummeln sich
nicht nur Verschwörungsanhänger.
Viele nehmen die Theorien mit Humor.
Einer von ihnen ist der
Journalist Rayk Anders.
Er beschäftigt sich auf seinem YouTube-
Kanal mit Verschwörungen aller Art –
und klärt auf.
Seine Videos erzielen mehrere
hundertausend Klicks.
Dass sie auf den ersten Blick selbst
verschwörerisch wirken, ist gewollt.
Ich hab dann immer solche Titel,
die halt immer so wirken,
als wäre ich jetzt komplett der
Anhänger der Verschwörungstheorien
und damit versuche ich,
die Leute so ein bisschen
aus ihrer Filter Bubble rauszuziehen,
dass sie sich vielleicht auf
das Video einlassen.
Und die naive Hoffnung meinerseits
ist dann immer ein bisschen,
wenn sie halt erst mal auf das
Video kommen durch den Titel
und dann vielleicht sehen,
dass der Inhalt ihnen vielleicht noch
mal neue Informationen geben kann,
dass sie vielleicht ihre eigene Haltung noch
mal überdenken oder hinterfragen.
Das sind Chemtrails.
Giftige Chemikalien, die von Flugzeugen
in den Himmel gesprüht werden.
Sie sollen zum Beispiel Lungenentzündungen,
Asthma und Alzheimer auslösen.
Alles im Auftrag einer
geheimen Weltregierung,
die die Menschen vergiftet.
So nicht, Sportsfreunde!
Der YouTuber hat eine klare Haltung.
Ich meine, man will ja wissenschaftlich
immer nichts ausschließen.
Das heißt in dem Moment, wo jetzt wirklich
eine große wissenschaftliche
Untersuchung kommt,
die dann festlegt, dass die Barcodes uns
allen Krebs besorgen oder was auch immer,
dann werde auch ich jeden
Barcode durchstreichen.
Ich meine, das ist ja schnell gemacht.
Aber ich warte einfach auf die Ergebnisse,
würde ich sagen.